and I ask members sorry can I ask
members to join with me in sending our
best wishes to councillor Wendy Turner
for a speedy recovery following her
recent announcement regarding her
illness we look forward to seeing her
back in the council chamber as soon as
she is feeling better now I first remind
you of some domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs cold water is
also available in the breakout area
outside the meeting room if the fire
alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it is safe to do so please switch off
all mobile phones or turn them to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
they're confidential or exempt items if
you make a representation to this
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to consented to being filmed by entering
the room you're also consented to being
filmed by the council and the possible
use of those images and sound recordings
for webcasting and/or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may film record or photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the press are not lawfully
excluded finally can members and
officers please ensure when you press
the microphone for speaking and you turn
it off when you're finished can I move
to the agenda please item number 1
apologies for absence Thank You chair we
have received apologies from councillor
Turner councillor Mansell is stuck on a
train and should be here shortly thank
you right a number 2 declaration of
interest by councillors are there any
declarations
no thank you
item number 3 MC / 19/20 3 to confirm
the minutes of the make meeting held on
26th of September 2019 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
yes councillor Ellen Thank You chair bit
concerned about paragraph 10-point
to 10.3 10.3 it's not really clear the
question was about staff and I think
there was a Lancer about stuff but it
only refers to start to resources in the
growth company and the growth company
isn't explained so I think that's a
little a little bit unclear are there
any other issues of accuracy okay can I
have it proposing please oh sorry I'm
countin up a much mo Isom Thank You
chair and I asked him at the as in the
notes
10:48 1049 last council meeting to
councillor Fleming and I asked about the
discontinued recycling of tetra packs
and the what happens to these at the
waste of food and it was suggested that
that would be answered after the meeting
and haven't received an answer so it's
wondering if that could be answered and
an answer provided to all members thank
you just to answer on that we are
collating all of those responses and
they will be coming out to you in the
next couple of days
I'm caster Pratt I think was did you
have your hand up cancel leave Ellen
Thank You chair just to say that there
were six other items mentioned in the
minutes where with questions were asked
and it was said that their answers were
going to provide it after the meeting
one has been provided today and I really
don't think that's good enough and if
the minutes are saying that a question
is going to be that information is going
to be provided then we're going to have
to start asking for a time frame because
it's not good practice to actually say
questions will be answered and then
they're not to be answered Thank You
chair fair enough
counselor arm stringer thank you page 24
15 14 it says it cancels disagree
becomes a stringer now that's that's
perfectly normal
that the issue I have with the minutes
is the words emergency climate and
change around the wrong way it should be
climate change emergency not emergency
climate change thank you okay thank you
we can amend that councillor Pratt yep
so just uh just a little typo on 15.1
three it says counsel Pratt suggested
new ideas were considered farmers who
were in trend in debt could provide
farmland for rebuild Ehrman's so rebuild
mondai I believe as a typo I just would
like to know if the ternary wildermann
to actually reflects the
administration's sentiment towards the
woodland motion that was rejected in the
previous meeting
yeah I'm councillor Nathan
Thank You chef yeah 10.30 7ri young i
thank council brewster for providing the
answer although only today but the what
was actually said didn't actually get
Milly to terribly accurately and I'm
very grateful two counts the geek who
seems to get these things written down
as fast as they're said and she's got a
correction which she'll give you in a
moment talking to ah there we go I can
turn on the microphone and I think it
should be something along the lines of
councillor Matheson asked why none of
the information relating to the recent
Cabinet report had been put to members I
think that makes more sense rather than
having that double negative and if
councillor Masterson agrees with me I
would suggest that that's what he said
okay we can amend that so can I have a
proposal for the minutes please thank
you
happy to Prost and then you minutes
madam chair thank you may I have a
seconder yes thank you all those in
favor all those against right that's
carry thank you moving on to agenda item
number 4 from for Chairman's
announcements I refer you to paper MC
slash 19/20 for to be noted and also I'm
going to take this opportunity to invite
you all to my civic service which will
be a pressing field church at 3:30 on
the 8th of December so moving on to
agenda item sorry um councilor Phillips
yeah as a matter of accuracy need to
market civic service on the 13th of
October it says the vice-chair attended
but he didn't actually attend all right
okay fair enough
thank you attend to item 5 leaders
announcements I would like to invite
councilor Morley to present her tables
update
in October we shared blueprints for the
Needham Lake Visitor Center which are
now being developed to create a high
quality and environmentally sustainable
building including a cafe and new public
convenience facilities this included a
drop-in event on Thursday the 10th of
October at Needham Market community
center we also carried out a survey at
the event and have continued to promote
this on social media
the plans complement the rural nature of
the site and aims to boost the number of
visitors to the lake each year
supporting the rural economy and
encouraging more people to enjoy a range
of outdoor leisure pursuits we're now
encouraging high quality innovative
tennen sorry we're now encouraging a
high quality innovative tenant to bid to
manage the new visitor center and cafe
thank you and success of national
democracy week including our counselors
seminar thank you to everyone who took
part in national democracy week during
the week our counsellors talked to
groups we don't often see in the council
chamber the week kicked off with a panel
of members from both councils holding an
hour-long live webinar with pupils at
Thurston Community College members
covered a range of topics from planning
to litter picking responding to
questions sent in life by the pupils
watching later in the week staff and
counselors set out to local markets to
speak with people about what the council
does and how it shapes our communities
giving market goers in Stowe Market the
chance to ask questions find out more
about services and discover what local
government means for them
national customer services week saw the
launch of our new customer charter
having identified our customers as one
of our five core values during must
national customer services week we
launched our Customer Charter which sets
out the clear standards which we expect
of our staff and what our customers
expect from us importantly customers
aren't just our residents but everyone
we interact with to deliver our services
this includes ourselves as counselors
colleagues businesses partners local
authorities suppliers and others the
weeks or staff and counselors challenge
to update their profile and a voicemail
among others tasks with stories shared
from staff based in our call centers we
want to make it clear to all employees
that customers are central to the work
we do every day and by making sure we
have a clear set of guidelines about
what our customers should expect from us
we can be consistent in our approach
monitor our performance get better at
listening to customer feedback and
improve our services if you would like
further information about the Charter
please to speak to myself or our
corporate manager for customers at Sam
Lake counselor open evening at the mix
in stone market is being held on the
12th of November I'd like to remind all
counselors of the open evening being
held at the mix in stone market you are
all invited to attend and hear about the
ways in which staff of the mix are
working to support young people it's
also an opportunity to hear from you if
you would like to attend you must
respond to the email invitation you
would have received on the 14th of
October during recycle week we were in a
series of social media posts throughout
the week to get residents thinking about
how they can reduce waste and recycle
better the posts included daily
challenges where answers could be found
on the Suffolk recycling website please
do encourage our residents to access X
the recycling do's don'ts and tips
online via the Suffolk recycling website
groups whether they are neighbors
community clubs or other can also sign
up for free education centers empty
homes week saw us encouraging residents
to report empty homes in the district as
well as seek out our empty homes
interest-free loans of up to twenty
thousand if they themselves own an empty
home following success will take up this
summer we have extended our free swim
program for Under 17's during this
October half term and the Christmas
holidays this will help to promote
healthy and active lifestyles in mid
Suffolk free swims available at mid
Suffolk measure Center in stone market
and Strad book swimming pool and fitness
center and please do encourage residents
in your Ward's to take part as I'm sure
you're aware planning for a total of 135
new homes were approved in February on
both the former HQ offices and the
former need a market middle school site
building work is due to begin later this
year and should be completed by the end
of 2020 we are continuing to promote our
tree for life scheme in mid Suffolk
which sees parents and carers of all
newborn or newly adopted children in
2019 able to apply for a free tree this
is ahead of this year's deadline in
January the scheme also includes an
option to apply for a memorial tree for
parents who have sadly lost a child
during this same period we will be
contacting successful applicants early
next year to confirm when they can
choose and collect their tree Thank You
chair
thank you very much
I did wonder we regards our counselors
currently been followed on social media
live there by V social media accounts as
I do believe National Director National
Archive inspects they would it would
actually be useful for able to share out
regard regards information to all our
demographic more all followers
is it possible for councillors of all of
all parties to be followed and if not
why not
just if I can clarify do you mean
followed by the council's account yes
counselor even thank you very much chair
I have two questions I may firstly this
is the fourth meeting in a row where we
haven't had leaders announcements in
good time
much of the information on here while
useful is at least a week old and we
could have been sent this report earlier
with an update at this meeting so please
could ask why this is such a consistent
practice secondly there's a headline at
the second paragraph up on page 4 saying
former middle former HQ so I don't need
him building work begins
yet it then says building workers do to
begin later this year so presumably work
hasn't actually begun yet but what my
question would be was with regards that
could you confirm how many social homes
and affordable homes are being built on
that site and what is the net amount of
housing we've provided in this financial
year that's taking into account right to
buy as well as houses that we've then
bought and houses that we're building
thank you very much chairman my report
is not a report its leaders
announcements and I'll get them out as
soon as I can I cannot promise that they
will be out ahead of time with the rest
of the papers they are purely that
announcements on the number of social
housing will have to come back to your
Met Council the string
don't think a chair in your leaders
announcements
could I ask missing from that for me was
the announcement from government about
the public works long board increase in
interest rate could you answer what
impact that's likely to have on our
social building program and our
investment program and then given that
we've got our millions of pounds who
have agreed to invest but not yet
borrowed yet
will we be revisiting those investments
and those decisions in the light of the
interest rate having gone up over 400
percent our portfolio holder and the
cabinet member ownio holder in the
section one five one officer are working
their way through those as we speak are
there any other questions so moving on
to UM agenda item six receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with council procedure rules Thank You
chair we have received a petition
containing 87 validated signatures
regarding planning application DC 1901
236 in Norton this petition will be
dealt with through the planning process
thank you agenda item 7 questions by the
public in accordance with council
procedure rules none received chair item
8 questions by councillors in accordance
with council procedure rules non
received her agenda item 9 MC / 19 star
26 overview and scrutiny committee
report I would like to invite councillor
Willem to introduce his report which is
been noting thank you chair you have the
report in writing in front of you I
guess or on your screens and I don't
think I need to read it out
any questions that I could answer or any
that I can't answer
counselor I'm autumn yes oh the work
you're doing and obviously the review of
the seal process I really feel that we
need to make sure I mean it seems quite
congrat congratulatory the scrutiny
report and certainly I was at a meeting
with the seal team and Network Rail I
really think we need to look at how
we're going to deal with these seal
beings in a much more strategic manner
so I'm hoping that as part of the review
team they will be able to consider that
okay thank you is there any other
questions for councillor William okay
moving on to agenda item 10 MC / 19
starter 27 corporate plan 2019 to 2027 I
would like to invite councillor morning
to introduce paper this paper and Ruth
the recommendation in the report Thank
You chair
as colleagues on the council are aware
we have been working on a cross-party
basis with our cabinet colleagues at
Baber to review the existing joint
strategic plan before it expires in 2020
this work and the prints of course we
have developed to guide the evolution of
the corporate plan are set out in
Appendix A the senior leadership team
have been supporting us in this work and
it has also been significantly informed
by officers from across both councils
I'm therefore really proud to now be
presenting this new joint corporate plan
19 2019 to 2027 on behalf of the cabinet
for full council approval of course the
nature and role of district councils has
not fundamentally changed the new
corporate plan therefore reflects more
of an evolution rather than a revolution
it does however provide a more
stretching joint vision for the future
of our areas and is designed to enable
us to address the challenges and seize
the opportunities facing our districts
and our councils for the foreseeable
future
the revised vision a new mission
statement will ensure that we provide
more confident leadership of our places
through greater place-based working our
interconnected
interconnected strategic priorities are
now firmly enshrined as being the
environment our economy housing
well-being our customers and our
communities
finally by embedding our newly adopted
values within the corporate plan we are
more deeply rooting our organization in
what we believe in genuinely caring
about our residents and places and
getting stuff done for people a
visualization of the revised corporate
plan is contained within the report but
I've asked that the chief executive
provides a more detailed PowerPoint
presentation which he will do once the
motion has been moved and seconded if
approved tonight then a further report
will be brought to cabinet to adopt the
corporate outcomes 2019 to 2023 which
you can see in
the orange segments at the top of the
diagram I propose if agreed by the chair
of overview of overview and scrutiny
committees to bring that report to the
joint overview and scrutiny committee
for discussion and debate first before
being presented for approval at cabinet
I therefore take great pleasure in
moving the recommendation at paragraph
3.1 that the council adopts the draft
corporate plan 2019 to 27 as visually
represented represented in paragraph
four point five to replace the refreshed
joint strategic plan 2016 2020 and I
call for a second
good evening members I'll just wait for
the technology to kick in so I can use
the PowerPoint there we go
so as the leader has already mentioned
that she's asked that I provide a more
detailed explanation of that one-page
diagram that you've got in front of you
please do bear with me there are 22
slides in terms of making sure that this
is more detailed and there's also a
short video as well which I will explain
in due course but I'll take you through
it step by step for those wishing to
look at the the report itself
I'm predominantly focusing and be
talking about the items set out within
Appendix A of the report so if you've
got that in front of you that hopefully
you will be able to follow that as I go
as well so thought I'd begin if I may
just by setting out what we mean by some
of the expressions that you will hear me
use a lot and that appear a lot within
the the diagram and those are the vision
the mission values and strategies so
when we say vision and you can see there
the vision statement within the document
itself when we say vision we're talking
about effectively describing the world
that we want to see and the future that
we want to see and I'll come on in due
course but you'll hear how the cabinet's
both for mid suffer come for Baber
have been very clear that they want that
to me a stretching vision they don't
want it to be something that's easy to
deliver a simple to deliver they want it
to be a stretch in that regard and
critically what needs to then go
alongside a vision is a mission and if I
just briefly refer back to the document
that you're replacing the joint
strategic plan as we previously held
that had no mission statement and that
was a real problem in my opinion for the
organization because it meant that the
organization and particularly the
officers but also counselors whilst we
had a vision and in fact we had to we
had subtly different one for Baber and a
subtly different one for mid Suffolk
there was no mission statement there was
no glue if you like to make that join
for officers between what they do day to
day all the way through to delivery of
the vision the councillors had set out
so the mission in that respect sets out
how the vision should become a reality
so it's that glue as I say in terms of
making that vision become a reality that
sets out what the whole document really
means for this council
in particular we then move on to the
values and hopefully you'll be familiar
with our values already I'll show you
those in a moment
but again that's a key element that was
missing from the previous version of the
joint strategic plan the the corporate
plan as we're now calling it that was
missing previously and again that's
critical for me because the values are
what sets the motivation as you see
there the heart behind the mission to
drive what it is that really
fundamentally motivates us in terms of
that delivery what we believe in as an
organization and so in the absence of
that we just had fine words we just had
a vision but with no mission and no
value sitting behind it underpinning it
so that's as one of the other key
changes and then lastly you'll see a set
of both strategies and strategic
priorities and I'll talk and a bit more
detail about those in a moment but
clearly they are important because they
set out the how they set out the tactics
by which we say we'll go forth and
actually deliver the vision that you
wish to see so that just sets out some
of the framework and as I say the
previous good strategic plan and the
refreshed version only had a vision and
some strategies it didn't have a mission
and value so whilst the document in
front of you is just one page rather
than the 30 pages that we had previously
is actually more in that one page than
there was in the previous incarnations
moving on then and I'm just going to
touch very briefly on values and
strategy because really what I want to
focus on is the vision and the mission
and where that diagram comes from so our
values will be familiar to you hopefully
they hung around my neck on my lanyard
you will have seen them within the the
office buildings that they are working
progress we are never going to be
finished in that regard in relation to
our values so whilst they were adopted
in the early part of this year there are
continued exercise of embedding them
into our organization making them
absolutely real to all of our officers
and hopefully also to all of our
counselors and they as I say set out
what we believe in that helps drive the
culture of the organization in
delivering the vision equally in terms
of strategies many of the strategies
that I'm going to talk about already
exist so you can see there a list of the
six key strategic priorities and how
they are encompassed specifically in
terms of strategy documents and you can
see we've also set out the dates of
each of the each of those various
documents have been adopted all the way
through to the ones that were most
recently adopted both the communities
and the homes and housing strategies
that were adopted just before the
elections in March the old one out there
if I flick over the slide your one out
clearly is the environment we do not yet
have a clear environment strategy and
that's part and parcel of why you set up
a task force alongside the climate
change emergency that you declared
earlier in this year so that that will
emerge from that task force in addition
though I'm just going to flick between
the two slides to do bear with me you'll
see there we have an economy strategy
that was adopted in February 2018 but
the economy is obviously constantly
moving and your assistant director Fiona
has already indicated in conjunction
with the portfolio holder her intents to
bring forward a revised economy strategy
during the course of roughly speaking
the next six months so that's one of the
ones that you will be seeing a refreshed
version of because our economic climate
our environment in that regard is
constantly in a state of flux and then
lastly in terms of these strategies
you'll see we have a leisure sports and
physical activity strategy but you are
all about and you were all happy for a
while all about health and well-being
not just sport in that context but the
wider health and well-being agenda and
so it is our intention if you me
corporate plan is adopted and I suspect
in any event to bring forward a revised
strategy that takes it beyond just being
about leisure centers and sports and be
much more firmly rooted in health and
well-being in all of its forms in that
regard so whilst we have as I say six
strategies in that regard they will
continue to evolve and that's critical
and I will use a sporting analogy and
I'll use a football analogy which is
dangerous because I know next to nothing
about football but I'll use the analogy
anyway which is if you think about any
given team and I'll let you choose your
relevant team playing on a Saturday or a
midweek game they change their tactics
depending upon who they play against
that week they will also playing them to
change their tactics depending on how
the games going during the course of
each of those games local government
dare I say it not just favor amid
Suffolk but local government broadly has
a habit of adopting strategies that then
stay as our strategies for four five six
years
and that's wrong in my personal opinion
so these strategies need to become much
more live documents there are tactics
and in that regard we need to be keeping
them a constantly under review as to our
our tactics working to deliver the
things that you want to see not blessed
our vision as a whole but our wider
outcomes that you want to see and if
they're not working that we are updating
our tactics on a much more live basis on
a much more regular basis so that
expectation is there in terms of these
particular strategies so just wanted to
touch on those briefly but focus more
specifically on the vision and the
mission as I say the vision being the
world you want to see in the mission
setting out our part as mid stuff again
how we make that vision become a reality
and so this corporate plan has been
developed over the course of time work
started on it just prior to the
elections and has continued since and as
the leader has already outlined that's
particularly been through the two
cabinets of the two authorities working
together on a on a joint and cross-party
basis and what they did at the outset
will set out some clear parameters and
you can see those set out as I say in
Appendix A and I just wanted to take you
through those in a little more detail so
first and foremost that we should have a
single clear and compelling vision
single is highlighted there because
that's not we what we don't currently
have we have two visions if you like we
have one for baby and one for mid
Suffolk that is complicating it is
unnecessary and it certainly holds us
back in terms of deliveries doesn't help
drive things forward but the vision
needs to be clear compelling and as I
said already stretching in that regard
that the whole document and the vision
itself needs to be a reflection of mid
Suffolk and Baber it shouldn't be the
case that what we produce simply could
be cut and pasted lifted if you like and
apply to any other rural district or
borough within England it should be much
more deep-rooted in our places in that
regard the one caveat I would add to
that is districts and boroughs provide
the same services so it's not surprising
that there will be some commonality
across various districts and boroughs
but the aspiration is there to be making
sure that this is very much a reflection
of our places that there should be a
golden thread and apologies for the
management speak but there should be
possible to make a thread all the way
through from the
the high-level vision that stretching
vision all the way through to every
single officers one-to-one and
appraisals and objectives that are set
on an annual basis and so you'll see
within the diagram that the ones or ones
in appraisals form part of that to make
that thread all the way through to what
officers do day to day on your behalf
that the plan should be a longer-term
plan and so what is proposed is that
it's an eight year plan but we are a
local government body we have elections
every four years and therefore that it
will be sensible to reflect on that plan
just prior to and just prior just
following each of our elections to make
sure that it's still relevant but that
it should be a long term eight year plan
and similarly that we check health check
it just after any general elections on
the basis that clearly a general
election can often lead to a change in
our environment a wider environment it's
sensible to make sure not just in terms
of our strategies but in terms of our
wider plan that it's still as relevant
as it possibly can be after a general
election which I understand could be
sooner than we think and the last bullet
point in relation to that is about the
audience now you would ordinarily expect
I suspect that we think in terms of this
being a document for the public it isn't
and this document is very clearly
earmarked and set out as being for you
for our councillors for our staff and
for our stakeholders that doesn't mean
that we shouldn't communicate it to the
public it doesn't mean that particularly
the vision shouldn't be part and parcel
of our engagement with our residents
with our electorate but the document
itself is about how we deliver as an
organization and they're putting us in
the best possible place to deliver as an
organization that isn't the thing we
should be engaging residents on what we
should be engaging with residents is
what they want to see us deliver not the
mechanics about how we go about doing it
in addition to that in terms of what's
important to achieve from this corporate
plan as I said already it should feel
beyond reach it shouldn't be the case
that any of you can stand on the
doorstep in three-and-a-half years time
and be able to go tick tick tick tick
we've delivered this it should be harder
than that
it should be something that's constantly
causing us to stretch further and
further but in broad terms if I were to
distill a whole of the vision down into
an
so it is always about for me improving
quality of life and that's what the two
cabinets have reconfirmed as well there
is a clear link on I I know I've got
planning colleagues in the room so
apologies to them the local plan is a
planning authority document it is a
technical document of course it is I'm
never gonna say it isn't but it's much
much more than that and you've heard me
say before how the local plan is our
blueprint and should be our blueprint
for what our district is going to look
like for the next 18 years and so there
should be a clear synergy between this
corporate plan and our local plan and
you see within the diagram and I'll
explain in G course how that comes
together but very deliberately we have
moved away from having a perfectly well
written 30 page document but a 30 page
document that didn't work for the
organization it has not made the
difference that you want to see in that
I would want to see for the organization
and so instead we're moving towards as
you see a single document a plan on the
page but supported by digital digital
materials and that's what I'm going to
play the video in due course as an
example it's not the example of digital
materials but just gives you a flavor of
the kind of things that we're looking to
produce a subject to approval of the
corporate plan by its very nature any
outstanding so I talked already about
those strategies that aren't yet in
place they would obviously be informed
by what the corporate plan is seeking to
achieve and similarly work the other way
and the aspiration is to make sure that
we look at all of those key strategies
both the external facing ones those so
those strategic priorities the six I
talked about already but also the more
internally facing ones things like the
medium-term financial strategy things
like our asset investment strategy and
make sure that there is a consistency a
thread running across all of them as
well which links back to the corporate
plan and as I said said already multiple
methods for communicating the vision the
mission and those strategic priorities
to our residents to the electorate to
the people that we're accountable for in
addition to talking about what it's
important to achieve what the two
cabinets have also looked at as a what's
equally important that this plan should
not be so not just what it should be but
what it should not be and they've taken
the view that we don't wish to adopt a
single model if you like as a council to
all of our approaches you may or may not
be familiar with other councils out
that have adopted things like the EZ
Council some councils detective living
the EZ Council which is like easyJet
where effectively you get a basic level
service and then anything else you have
to pay extra for or the commissioning
council where the council effectively
splits itself in to has a commissioning
department that determines what it wants
to see and then Commission's others
within the organization and outside of
the organization to deliver those on on
their behalf and you can see other
examples there the point being the
cabinet's don't want to simply adopt a
sip one-size-fits-all single model we
are a complex at times complicated and
exciting organization as local
government and therefore we need more
flexibility than that similarly what we
shouldn't be doing is simply saying that
we're going to do everything and our
corporate plan in that regard sets
parameters in that regard as to what we
are not as much as what what we are it
shouldn't be style over substance that
should always be the case and what it
doesn't seek to do very deliberately is
it doesn't seek to try and set all of
the context within which we operate
because that context constantly changes
and so if it was trying to do that the
document will be out of date very
quickly as part of the development not
just the cabinets but also a whole
series of officer sessions have been
held read prior to mostly prior to the
elections if I just flip one's life
forward yes so over 106 officers engaged
through a variety of staff briefings and
also the extended leadership dean and
the city leadership team and we focused
not what on not just on what we want to
be for the future and change is good in
that regard but we've also focused on
what we don't need to make sure that we
preserve because there's lots about mid
Suffolk that's fantastic already in
terms of how we deliver things and we
don't want to lose that in that respect
and so these are the things I'll let you
read them to yourselves where I pick out
a few so caring for our districts our
sense of duty being friendly and
welcoming as an organization being
greater than the sum of our parts the
richness and strength and authenticity
of our relationships our local knowledge
of our places our links to those
communities how we value in how we act
as custodians of those places and how we
work to protect and enhance the
strengths of our character and
characters of our various communities
those are the things that officers say
we already do and that we need to make
sure we don't lose through this constant
this evolutionist has been described by
the leader so as I said already a series
of staff briefings away days and joined
cabinet discussions if I distill
everything that I've set though down
into a very small nutshell of four
bullet points quality of life as I say
over arches everything it should be
about ambition and aspiration
it's about prosperity and valuing our
places and I would say also not just
reflecting historical qualities but
respecting those historical qualities as
well so if I now come on to the document
the diagram itself and the best way to
think of this is a bit like a dartboard
and we're working from the inside out so
that the very inside as I said already
the world we want to see that vision
statement great communities building
great communities with bright and
healthy futures that everyone is proud
to call home but as I've said already
needs to be supported by a mission
statement so providing strong proud and
inspirational leadership striving for
excellence and together bringing web
sorry building great communities for
everyone to live work visit and invest
in so those two components form the
heart of the document the heart of your
corporate plan and then as I described
earlier the local plan is the next
component part and the next component
part very deliver deliberately because
it is that blueprint that describes what
the world what our world in terms of mid
Suffolk should look like for that next
18 years and so again the local planners
can put right bang in the center just
alongside the vision and the mission as
we then work out from the document or
outwards within that circle you can see
those six strategic priorities that I
talked about already they aren't new as
I said we've had those we've had those
strategies in place already although it
may be the first time that we're
expressly stating them as six strategic
priorities in that regard and they are
very deliberately shown in a circle with
arrows going round like that because
none of them is deemed to be more
important nor less important than any
the others they need each other in that
respect whatever we do in relation to
housing clearly has a component part in
relation to the environment in
communities what we do and well being
has a link in terms of the economy and
the environment and so on and so forth
they are linkage and symbiotic with each
other and that's why they they hang
together in that
more than anything else though what I've
talked about so far is documents and
diagrams they only become real
by virtue of people local government is
at people based business that's all of
you as our councillors that's all of our
offices is all of our stakeholders so
those dots that look a little bit like
corporates they aren't supposed to be
poor prints and there's supposed to be
people and they they symbolize the fact
that this is about putting all of that
together in terms of driving that's to
say that golden thread through to
everything that we do and very
deliberately wrapped all the way around
the outside is what we believe in so our
values so that linkage from our people
and what they believe in and what we
believe in as an organization in terms
of driving that forward and then the
very last component part are the more
internal strategies if you like so our
people strategy on medium-term financial
strategy our assets and investment
strategy the nuts and bolts of things
that you would expect us to have as an
organization and we need to have as an
organization but again they need to all
be part and parcel because if any one of
those components is missing it doesn't
work it won't work in terms of our
overall delivery so they all hang
together in as well so as I said earlier
just want to play a very brief video by
just give you an explanation as to what
this is hopefully many many of you will
have seen it already because as you walk
around the offices it is playing on the
large screens in those offices it was
prepared in the early part of the summer
for our staff conference and it was also
prepared as part of wider marketing
materials for recruitment more generally
but you will be familiar and noticed
some of the expressions because
obviously it's been prepared in
conjunction with the development of this
document as well so if I
[Music]
from first light we start working a
[Music]
brand mid Suffolk are really great
places with fantastic Bright Futures but
what's even more important and what
makes them fantastic other people the
residents and the tenants that will work
for our councillors who volunteer their
time to our communities and all of our
staff were incredibly proud and
passionate and care about their
communities and making them even better
for the future everyone deserves a safe
warm home we're working hard to build
new homes and create settle communities
to help our residents live happy and
healthy lives we've helped thousands of
families with our home select scheme and
helped return over 300 previously empty
homes back into use
we're working to make paper amid Suffolk
communities healthier happier and safer
places to live we've committed millions
of pounds to replace enough herbage
much-loved community assets such as
village halls community centers play
areas and sports facilities through
funding advice and grants we support
hundreds of projects like this new skate
park in Sudbury so that communities can
revitalize their local area keeping
Baber and mid Suffolk clean and litter
free is really important to us our teams
and lots of volunteers go out and click
thousands of tonnes of waste and
recycling every year customers come
first for us that's the bottom line our
customer service staff know Baber and
mid Suffolk really well we've created
new service points across our district
with faizon's of visits one of our most
important jobs is securing the right
type of house in the right place it's
not just about new homes
we're helping local businesses set up
with the right facilities in the right
places
this creates jobs for our residents and
supports our economy
this is how we're helping to make vapor
amid suffered great places that people
want to call home at the end of the day
we're all about preserving what's
fantastic in Weber amid suffer making
bright futures for all of our residents
and ensuring that everyone is proud to
call us home
[Music]
so said already that that video wasn't
produced specifically for the corporate
plan and more particularly although you
are all in it very briefly if you
blinked you will have missed it but you
will have seen some filming I'm not sure
if you even knew the filming was
happening and you are in it very briefly
but obviously in relation to the
corporate plan if it's adopted tonight
that's the kind of digital material not
just that that we would look to produce
to provide their explanation
particularly for our public but
critically you would be in it a lot more
in that regard as well because as I say
at the moment counsellors aren't in it
in that regard so I've got one last
slide you were pleased to hear
technology work okay so what next so
subject to your approval of the
corporate plan tonight and the leaders
already alluded to this there is a lots
that comes next but one of the key
components comes next are the corporate
outcomes so the specific corporate
outcomes that you would want to see over
the course of the next four years
running up to the next set of elections
they aren't fixed in that regard they're
not set in stone but it's important that
we have those and I'm certainly
considering those as being the senior
leadership steam service plan if you
like in terms of what those should look
like and as the leaders already alluded
to that subject to her conversation with
the chair of scrutiny those would come
through for consideration at joint
scrutiny first before coming through to
cabinet for approval let's just give you
a sense of what comes after
consideration of this document so that's
all I had to say and I'll hand you back
to the general
so we'll now go into questions counselor
eben
thank you very much chair I'm afraid
afters presentations raised much more
questions and almost to confusion them
than I had before you mentioned at one
point you mentioned lots of didn't
tactics you've talked about a plan on a
page but I've heard that from many
several chief executives literally and I
seem to recall sitting in a room where
we many years ago talking about the
brightest future for our residents so
I'm glad to see that that's still there
but going back to the tactics point you
kind of how one of my concerns is how
would I see how would I relate this plan
to residents I can't see from what I've
got here how this is it's helping
president or residents sorry how do they
get involved with the constant review
that you mention and the change of
tactics that that are going on so how
does this plan help residents and how do
I translate it for them and secondly you
mentioned this is a document for you
I've seen you mean us here and our
stakeholders but then you say that
residents aren't aren't part of that and
thirdly if I may you talked about the
amount of people that were involved in
this but none of the counselors on this
side of the chamber have been involved
and given that you know we represent a
large number over 50% of residents in
this district you know isn't that isn't
that a rather bigger mission at this
stage thank you
I'll deal with the officer based ones
and leave the politics to others if I
may in terms of the tactics and this
document say yes just by way of
explanation I'll try and explain what I
said so from my perspective I wouldn't
suggest that you try and take this
document and explain it to a resident
that as I said is not what it's for
oommen you can't of course you can and
and it certainly if any resident wish to
sit down and talk talk to me through it
or anyone else through it more than
happy to do so the point I was trying to
make is it's that kind of digital
material that would help explain it far
more than simply being a document you're
absolutely right I think you won't find
the chief exec that doesn't talk about a
plan on a page I would argue you sort of
had a plan on a page as in there was a
page with a plan on it you just had
another twenty nine pages attached to it
so it wasn't really whereas this is a
genuine attempt at the other request of
counselors to try and distill it down to
simply that one page in terms of the
tactics again more than happy to sit
down and try and explain those to
residents as we go but it's it's those
strategies that set out what those
tactics are and and again I think the
key thing for me and I hope this isn't a
statement of naivety we should be
engaging with our communities to help
define those tactics but ultimately more
importantly than that I would say it's
our job to engage our communities to
find out what they want us to do it's
then for us to worry about the tactics
of making that become a reality and
whether we are around and so the tactics
whilst they well totally open and
transparent and my point being we need
to be much more alive to our things
actually working rather than simply
putting something on a page and leaving
it alone for a number of years so they
need to be much more lively and much
more monitored managed and checked in
that in that respect but fundamentally I
would still come back to the fact for
the residents they don't care whether
the tactics working they just want to
see the outcome and so it's the focus on
the outcome for them that's more
important for me that said clearly in
different spaces within this plan
whether that's the economy whether it's
the environment whether it's housing all
of those different elements you would
want and I would want to make sure that
we are this isn't just a conversation
amongst ourselves but we are drawing
upon and learning from and listening to
our residents in that context as well I
don't that helps up hopefully I hope so
and thank you very much chair because
I've just we know if we're talking about
engaging communities as to what they
want to do then then why haven't we you
see this just seems a premature we
haven't actually had that engagement and
that consultation to start with and you
know we talk about the corporate
outcomes piece of work going being
discussed over the in scrutiny committee
again that's so that's not happened yet
so none of none of these things none of
this engagement that has occurred to
actually try to decide what what we want
to achieve so it just seems premature
thank you so in terms of these sort of
build up of the document if you like all
the build up of the process there has
been and you are constantly engaging
with your communities in a variety of
ways so you adopted a Housing Strategy
adopted a community strategy earlier
this year that involved engagement with
the communities you are dialoguing with
your communities on a daily basis and
that clearly are representatives of them
in that regard as well so there is no
sensible starting point but effectively
what this document inks providing that
framework if you haven't got that
framework then you haven't got the
things to bolt into it in that respect
so we've started with that framework and
then it's a constant evolution evolution
from there but it's also a balance
between and I will say this as an
officer a balance between that
engagement with the communities and
asking them what they want and your
community leadership role of providing
them with some of those answers as well
and it's that balance between the two
it's not always one or the other it was
certainly not one of the other is that
that balance between the two and
providing that leadership and vision I
would argue you should come from the
council Council it's possible yeah thank
you very much chairman I was just gonna
say perhaps we should recommend after
the chief executive for a BAFTA award
after that two films you're very
impressed with it Arthur and but I'm
more serious now I actually think this
is this is a very very good starting
point and I'll tell you why I think that
and I would be interested in your
comments yeah just dump it
just get there so what I was going to
say was before I was interrupted taking
point if this is to be seen at a very
high-level strategy surely it is up to
us then to engage with the communities
to develop as you say the tactics are so
many in order to feed in underneath so
the question there really is how would
we see that happening it's clearly an
iterative process which i think is ideal
I think it's got most of the strands in
there what sort of mechanism might you
be thinking of as to how we can then
feed in and how it would be change
you're going to have working groups or
what sorts of methods can we have for
feeding in well after all this part of
our role that's the question
so for me you've got two main components
and they're they set out within that
document which is the customers
component and the community's component
so what you didn't have when you adopted
the community strategy earlier in the
year was the piece of work that needed
to run alongside that which is the
action plan so you set out again you
said that the framework that the team
through this isn't director through Tom
Barker are working on the development of
that action plan and that will set out
how you engage on a regular basis with
your communities in not just in terms of
the community space but on all these
different variety of topics so that will
help you in that in in that respect but
it clearly isn't a one-size-fits-all and
hence my point about tactics in terms of
what works what works in a rural area
will be different to what works in a
town what works in one town will be
different to what works in another town
it's about how can your local knowledge
in that regard of to who those key
players are in those in those spaces to
engage with at that time right my
preference no ideal from my perspective
as chief executive is that get to the
stage whereby you are consulting less
often but on really important things but
you are engaging 24/7 365 and more often
than not that is listening rather than
talking to and that's not easy to do and
that's it has to involve a variety of
things social media that we talked about
earlier was one component of that you
clearly go out and many of you will
attend all very nearly all of your
parish council meetings we have parish
the airs all meetings there's a whole
mix in there but that's a good point in
terms of a good point to mention in
terms of
tactics if some of those work sometimes
clearly don't work and we don't want to
simply be required locating processes
across the district if really they're
not having traction in that respect so
yes I would agree that this provides
that framework and then it builds and
builds and builds from there councilor
field did you have a question it's you
know really echoes some of the things
have been said already I find a ways to
be honest when I look at these sort of
documents I tend to feel they produced
no great harm that don't provide any
great direction one doesn't often see
significant changes in people's behavior
because they've seen a pretty diagram
with a number of top level strategies
described well though I do find your
comments that's a strategies should be
adaptive and respond to current
situations it is clearly correct they
don't need to be put in stone for a
number of years although I noticed
nowhere in this document anything that
described speed of response as one of
our our ideals if you like we see many
things to say we should we should have
bright and healthy futures everybody
should be proud to call myself a town
and it seems totally and out the obvious
that that is the sort of thing we would
all want across the piece and clearly as
you're saying perhaps the main work is I
do on corporate outcomes my real
question is that in the past such
documents of these have been produced in
a in a number of workshop type events
with involvement from right across the
council what of course this council and
a fiber in the last ones that I can
remember I just wondered why that has
not been done here at all in in this
particular case
it could have been absolutely and I
think it comes back to the point that
the leader made earlier
you've not started from scratch with
this this has got your work from
previous incarnations written all the
way through it and so this has been an
evolution of what you already had a
condensing and a coalition of what you
already had rather than starting from
scratch we absolutely could have had and
can have if you wish lots and lots of
workshops my priority is to get quickly
to a position where you're delivering
outcomes not spending lots of time
sitting in workshops particularly not if
you're concerned that it ends up with
the same stuff anyway in that respect so
I take the point absolutely we could
have done on this occasion we haven't
it's not--there's no management in that
it's not no nothing necessary to be read
more more significantly into it than
that but it's critical the one point I'm
not sure if it was a question but it
just wants to come back on it you are
absolutely right if it was a question
which is the just having a document
isn't going to make a blind bit of
difference to how my staff perform but
without that document I haven't got that
start point to be able to have that
dialogue that engagement start to begin
to change the cultures and the
behaviours it's exactly the same as just
having the values written on a lanyard
round my neck isn't embedding values
it's everything else that we do
alongside that so we have a session with
the extended leadership team on Tuesday
in anticipation hope that this is
approved that we will then work through
with them as to how we then take that
forward with the staff to really make
this real for them and particularly if
you look on the on the wheel at the the
bottom quadrants if you like so the
appraisals and the one two ones the key
thing for me about that isn't as I said
before making during that golden thread
the previous incarnation that you had
the 30 page document bluntly when I
asked staff have they read it they're
very honest and say no for those that
have read it it hasn't made any
difference to what they do either
because we didn't follow through I would
suggest with making it real for them
translating it for them and having those
that conversation with them as to what
does this mean in the context of your
job what does this mean in the context
of your team can you see yourself in
this picture so that we are greater than
the sum of our parts it's not just a
planning officer delivering planning or
a building control officer but
delivering building the role that we're
joining it all up and it's a lot how we
collectively contribute so the better
outcomes for the district as a whole so
yes you're right and those plans are
impressed in place to make sure that it
does become both embedded and real for
people so it does make a difference
because otherwise I wouldn't bother
doing this arakata thank you failing not
so Oscar aund councillor part part
Sports commenter would it be war rotten
tomatoes rather anything else but but
it's just introduced and it's a phrase
that's used by yourself as well cross
party I was just wondering which parties
has this been the work of and also will
say cake cake in terms of cross party
say it's the makeup of the two cabinets
obviously the cabinet with in mid
Suffolk contains both conservatives and
an independent within baver contains
conservatives independents and Liberal
Democrats Council Humphreys
I'm sure thank you I agree with
councilor Passmore this is a great plan
it's a great start and we all are
sorry somebody speaking it is a great
question that's coming in but I'm being
polite unlike you
so please want to speak in you'll have
your turn later so the question comes
from this in my other role in my other
world I actually deal with tactics those
tactics aren't just thought up they come
from somewhere they come from experience
they come from success they come from
failure and ultimately have come from
lessons identified the point I'd like to
ask is do we have a lessons identified
matrix and if so how do we feed into
that to make it more efficient
we do have an exercise of making sure
that from a project and program planning
perspective that we're constantly
learning lessons chewing on those
mistakes and I do it with you were
pleased to hear or not but I actively
encourage our staff to make mistakes
because if we're not making mistakes
we're not making a difference ultimately
we're not stretching ourselves in that
regard so yes we have a process
combination of proactively through that
project and project program management
and then if you like reactively in terms
of our area
risk management as well and that
includes lessons learned closed down
procedures at the end of projects if
members aren't already widely involved
in that we can expand that to make sure
that you are so that you can't feed into
all of those components that tends to be
through the cabinet but there's no
reason why that can't be more widely
spread councillor Scott thank you well
we've heard from the chief executive of
how it was dealt with on a cross-party
basis I have to say it was inevitable to
be dealt with on a cross-party basis
because Babers cabinet is cross-party
what we haven't heard from and I won't
expect the chief executive to do it but
I would like an answer from the leader
is why was it not done on a cross-party
basis thus far here at mid suffered
because I don't think the question is
actually been answered
as I've already said it's a refresh of
what has gone before which was
cross-party and at the end of the day
this is a cabinet administration plan
the next phase which will be the
outcomes will be going to scrutiny and
people will have a chance to get
involved with it then the world Thank
You chair can I follow on with the
football analogy if customers have to
use your term I don't like the players
in the team the leader and the team are
changed that's happened in the place
just a few hundred yards away from here
so I asked the chief executive is what's
this part of he's thinking and it's the
plan flexibly enough to accommodate I've
got four other questions cross-party
sorry to come back to that but I really
think you need to explain how the views
of the majority voters in mid suffit
were taken into account it is not the
job of of overview and scrutiny to find
out what the majority of people if
they'd suffered wouldn't want it in the
plan I'm sorry but it isn't so next is
our vision to build your vision to build
great communities and so on we read a
lot in there about what the offices want
the officers want they clearly had a
very significant input but whose vision
is it is it a vision that came from the
so called cross-party group or is it the
opposite vision if the corporate plan
I'm not I'm not complete confusion
because we've we read that the corporate
plan is for counselors staff and
stakeholders so my question would be
what document is available for service
users and residents to not use the
customer term and but then the chief
executive says it is for residents so is
it or isn't it and my last question is
when we look in the wheel of fortune
there's no mention there of the
community strategy is that a mistake or
should or should he be put back in so
again I'll try and stay away from the
politics and the first question is it
flexible enough to adapt I'm assuming
that as I said I'm not good at football
I'm assuming your analogy was it if
there were political change with it with
the plan was laid up enough to adapt to
that political change um bluntly no I
don't think it would but not least
because if there was a change of
administration you would want to change
it you didn't have to of course but I
would expect you so whenever there's any
change of administration I would expect
that administration to want to put their
stamp on things like the corporate plan
and particularly the objectives and the
outcomes that you're looking to achieve
so you could keep it you could
absolutely are more will more likely
expect to change it I don't think
there's anything more I can add in terms
of what I've said already about
engagement consultation and the views
but in terms of the vision no it's not
the vision of the officers it's very
clearly the vision developed by the two
cabinets supported by officers it's not
the officer's words I've got on a
different PowerPoint slide plethora of
different words that officers came up
with in terms of thinking to aid that
process but ultimately the selection of
the vision and the mission in that
regard
has come from the two cabinets the
corporate plan just to cover any any
inconsistency or if there's any
confusion everything that we do is for
our residents this document is not being
produced for our residents it doesn't
mean they can't read it of course they
can they can watch and listen to my
explanation of it just now if they
really want to so it's there for them in
that regard but it's not been built and
designed as a tool to engage with them
it's built as a tool to make us as an
organization effective in terms of
delivering the outcomes that you want to
see and that our residents want to see
and then lastly I didn't write down
enough things so what was your last
question sorry strategy but there's lots
of strategies on the way in a 4-2 but
the community strategy isn't there it's
there it's the so on the six on that
inner ring starting on top of
environments the next one along C is the
Orion
one communities says it says communities
yes I agree that it's got these
strategies around the outside but it's
not it's not mentioned they're there for
clarity each of those six I've referred
to them an expression that I use as
those those are our strategic priorities
so the economy environment community's
well-being customers and housing each of
those as I described earlier in the
slides has a strategy underpinning it so
those six that are referred to three of
which are under review or still emerging
the other strategies the things that sit
around the outside the ones you're
referring to in terms of medium-term
finance strategy assets investment etc
those are internal strategies they're
about how we operate as an organization
internally whereas those six about how
we operate externally so for shorthand
we just haven't added the word strategy
again but where you look at those purple
green orange pink blue and black green
arrows going round those strategic
priorities each of those is a strategy
as well Thank You chair and this is a
very brief question it's just on the
vision I think it's very clear that we
need to get this bit right but there's
something about the kind of the syntax
of that sentence which is a little bit
unwieldy one of that could be revisited
it does seem to feel like we we are
proud to call the future home rather
than the community and one of that could
be looked at just to kind of tighten it
up somehow Thank You Q councillor Carter
any other questions
cancer scar okay
thanks Jay we're coming back to what the
leader said in answer to my question I
thank you for your explanation but I
think although it's an evolution of
previous processes which was cross-party
under different capsules not this
council as in terms of its it makeup now
why could you have not recognized that
mid Suffolk now has many different and
new counselors that could have made a
contribution to this project councillor
stringer Thank You Geoff I wasn't
intending to say too much on this but
the more I hear the more confused and
frustrated I get I have an awful lot of
time we're in debate now are we
I thought we were in debate sorry I'll
wait to it so we'll move to debate now
so I'm counselor stringer would you like
to start
Thank You chair that's nice as I said
previously the more I hear the more
slightly confused I get as well as
frustrated after say I have an awful lot
of time for our chief exec if he knows
that I have immense respect for him but
for him to come up and say today he
doesn't to get involved in politics I
think you just waded you size nines
right through the middle of it frankly
with this document I get the idea of
mission statements if you're going to
draw up a mission statement you've got
to take everybody with you and to
suggest that 50 percent of the road has
no input into this process frankly I
find insulting I don't believe that we
have all of the good ideas over there
we've had some excellent questions from
across the other side of the chamber
tonight I wouldn't be so blind or so
silly to think that we had the franchise
on good ideas but to suggest that we had
no idea or no
think constructive we could have put
into this process I find frankly
insulting I have huge issues with
mission statements and strap lines
because I think any any organization
that needs to come up with one there's
got a problem you've identified a
problem in the paper 4.3 it says that
the council's need to focus upon
providing more confident leadership well
hang on we've had confident political
leadership since 2003 haven't we
so how come we've gotten to this muddle
that we then need to have some strap
line and a document that confuses and is
not for the public it's just for the
workers we should have been able to
ingrained the ethos of mid stuff with
them paper into our workforce without
having to come up with this stuff I'd
like to quote a really good strap line
for you
so if you can guess who this is our aim
is to ensure we are working at every
step to limit the impact of our business
has on the environment while maximizing
the social and economic benefits that
travel can bring as Thomas Cook that was
done about six months ago brilliant so I
think this document shows there been a
lack of clear political leadership here
I think we do have some problems within
the culture of our organization it's had
all sorts of issues over the over the
years and it's been put down to various
issues oh it's because of the move
people are settling down and various
things and we never quite seem to get
there I really really wish this document
would get somewhere near it but I
frankly don't think it will and and to
put a document out that shows people are
just being white and featureless is you
know you've really got to be careful
about what stuff we print and prepare it
and I think this is a bit of a mistake
and it's out within the mission of it I
don't understand why the vision and the
mission aren't the same I can't
understand that for a minute why do you
want to exclude working and investment
from our vision I don't know but equally
what's missing from it what I love to
report in here why not make me itself
like a great place to come and create in
or
be inspired by that's not even in our
vision or our mission statement so I
really really think it's a missed
opportunity and I really really feel bad
that we weren't able to have any part of
this at all Thank You councillor Mansell
thank you first of all politics of being
late please play Greater Anglia I am
I've listened with interest to what has
been said about this draft corporate
plan and personally I'm in favor of
something that is simple and on one page
because I don't like reading 30 page
documents either I tend to have a policy
that any report I write six to one sheet
of a4 because people aren't going to
read it so the concept of having a
visual representation of a corporate
plan I'm totally behind that but we've
heard that this is is based on the
previous incarnation of our strategic
plan and I'm sure I'm not the only
person in the room who was here for a
bit years ago when we did discuss that
previous incarnation shortly after the
last round of elections and and yeah we
had some workshops and it was great
because we got to know some of our
colleagues over in Bebo we got to know
one another
we had joint workshops and we came up
with the 30 page document that we're now
trying to develop so I too am absolutely
flabbergasted that we didn't have any
involvement in 50% of the council which
has already been said so you know it
just seems wrong to me that you know
since that previous incarnation which we
were talking about four and a bit years
ago the council has completely changed
its structure there are an awful lot of
people who weren't here for a bit years
ago and there you know salvus were there
and yeah we had a little bit of input
but we have no ownership fifty percent
of the people in this room have no
ownership of this corporate plan and if
we if it's got to be our values and our
beliefs and we've got to go and use it
in our work with our parishes sorry we
need some owners
I'll leave it there for now listen to
what other people have counseled Bieber
thank you very much chair um I messaged
my ID I too was here four and a half
years ago discussing this and and for
the previous four and a half years years
ago discussing similar corporate plans
or strategies and so on but I just find
it's so disappointing
what's in front of me I mean I'm
repeating what others have said we've
had no roundtable discussions we've had
no workshops of fellow members and
colleagues no consultations with the
communities that we all serve it's been
signed off by a small group of
counselors they're not necessarily
representative of everyone and I did to
get representative Sam's or but but but
not all and remember you know you guys
opposite me you can put these things
through through casting votes so that's
that's fine but wouldn't it be great to
engage us on this side and beyond that
this plan would have been a fantastic
opportunity to engage across our
district with residents with businesses
with charities with young people look at
the reaction to the thirst and community
college you know and that gets
replicated when we all go and talk to
young people and with all the counselors
in fact all the people have been
identified earlier in this meeting and
it's this states is this we're signing
off appear on a plan for eight years yes
you can say it's going to be constantly
reviewed and refreshed and so on but
with such a time commitment that we
should be signing this off where there's
been so little involvement with the most
important people it should be serving
that is not the people in this chamber
you know and as such you know I can't
support this and I personally think it
should be deferred until there's been
proper consultation across the whole
district thank you very much chair
councillor Passmore thank you very much
chairman well neighbors say I don't
entirely agree with you there Rachel I
think they reserved an unnecessarily
pessimistic view of this because I think
this is a very good starting place but
there is obviously up to all of us and I
do mean that
you're saying it to get involved to put
our views forward and you know I think
many times in the past
you tried to consult something you start
with a blank sheet of paper you've got
no starting point now you have your
views you quite taunt them that's
absolutely fine that's what it's about
but this is a good proposal I think a
lot of the themes in here and ideas are
exactly what we need for example if you
look at the economy how do we actually
help develop the economy what is the
role of the district counts in relation
to everything else
there's obviously loads of organizations
that get involved in it but that's
really really important we had a debate
last council meeting on the environment
and so on that is there as they clear
keyblock and it's really important we do
look at things be it tree planting
schemes public transport carbon
footprints there is a huge opportunity
there for everybody to have an input but
if we don't have these various themes
set out in the first place I would
suggest we're going to end up spending
probably another six eight months maybe
a year trying to get this off the ground
so I hear what you say but I have to say
I'm going to support this I think it's
rather good it's an iterative process we
will all have the chance to put input in
there and surely that's a good way to
get going and then Susie said at the
beginning it is a bit of a refresh of
what we set down some of us and all of
us except there four years ago so for me
chairman it's a very good starting point
and instead of being unnecessarily
critical and I think we should at least
give it a chance but also take a full
part in developing it and as we think is
fit for mid Suffolk stroke weber strokes
upper step whatever unites Richardson
thank you very much chair and then I
think two main points I think I'd like
to make in as part of this debate I
think the first which I find a bit BIM
using is that most of the criticisms of
this plan have been about the process by
which it was put together and not about
what councillors would have contributed
had they've got had they had the
opportunity to do so in this debate this
is the chance where if you think there
is something missing from this plan
say so and we can debate that we can
discuss that there's been very little I
think counselor past mores comments
there's been very little actual debate
about the substance of what we are
discussing and I think that's
particularly what I want to draw up on
councillor past Moore has mentioned the
economy there's one particular aspect of
this plan that I would like to talk
about which is health and well-being
because the relationship between sport
and leisure and wider health and
well-being
it is obvious but I think it shouldn't
be overstated I think it's something
that's just I shouldn't be understated I
think it's incredibly important that we
use this as an opportunity when we
discuss it it scrutiny when we look at
developing these proposals further that
we in mid Suffolk and in baver
work with our partners in the Suffolk
and Northeast Essex STP a lot of the
plans and the priorities they have
around Public Health tie in exactly and
aligned with exactly the kind of things
we can look at as part of our work
health and well-being strategy things
like reducing obesity reducing
loneliness reducing health inner core
inequalities across the districts those
are really important things that can
have a real tangible benefit across the
districts and can have a real positive
impact on the NHS and I would really
hope that that is part of the outcomes
that we look to obtain as part of that
particular strategy and so for that
reason and for much of the other areas
that we are prioritizing as part of this
plan I would really support this
corporate plan and we'll be voting in
favor of it councillor Hicks thank you
very much and I think you you've
absolutely nailed it what's interesting
today and actually I'm really really
disappointed in the opposition I think
it's a really sad day that the
opposition is now coming in here and
every opportunity just finding criticism
of the administration rather than
working with us it's really disabled
so it is so to the point of order chair
could the speaker list the opportunities
really had to this document speak gnosis
trigger and what I think is really
disappointing is you just come in here
and oppose it for the sake of it
this is a good plan that has been
thought through that lays foundations
for us as an administration to move
forward of course you're going to come
in here and find fault in it you're the
opposition there are only eleven green
councilors there are seventeen
conservative well eleven today twelve
normally there are seventeen of us you
are not the administration you are the
opposition so it'd be much better if you
could actually come in here and start
working with us and say great plan let's
tweak it this way this is what we can do
rather than coming into every meeting
and just for the sake of it opposing
disappointing so I am also extremely
disappointed but for another reason and
I will be supporting this paper Thank
You counselor I'm sure thank you on the
same theme really I'm also disappointed
as you might might have established I
look at this and I wouldn't know what
you would change honestly I know it's
seriously what you would you change
every headline is in there everything we
need to be concerned about is in this
plan this by the way it's a plan what
the plans do they evolve over time to
see environment G to circumstance our
control environment new technology or
different ways in which this will though
evolve over time and you will be evolved
without a shadow of a doubt and you're
absolutely right
every time you come in and you knock
things would you know what be
constricted you might get more support
from us and from people outside this
chamber the facts are there is nothing
here that is really really bad this is
all good it's a great plan that's going
to evolve over time and by the way just
so it clear we didn't have any
involvement either but we're not
complaining because this is a good plan
we'll get my full support so stop
whinging get on board
Thank You chair well plenty has been
said already about that the the
legitimacy and lack of legitimacy of the
documents I won't go over any of that
again other than to just remind people
that there's 59 percent of the voters
were not represented in preparing it but
the might the other reason I would
certainly not be supporting any document
frankly that has the word customers so
centrally installed in it the word is is
inaccurate as regards our residents and
what is worse it's counterproductive and
it will work contrary to the vision and
to the mission and to the livery of
quality of life and that's just
ridiculous when you think about it not
then it's been mentioned the work that
was done for you eight years ago yes
interestingly eight years ago I asked
the the assembled multitude of the two
councils as they then were when we first
met them really when we were talking
about how to work together I asked them
whether they wanted to use the word
customers in the vision statement that
was being prepared at that time and the
answer by about 75 percent was no don't
like the word so nothing changed there
we still got the wrong word in there we
know that we've reintroduced the word
because we did drive it out for what
four or five years Andrew I'm cancelling
alright I'm pressing the wrong button
perhaps um Thank You chair cancer hub
priests says there's nothing in the plan
that's contentious and that's true
you're absolutely right there that's
largely because there's very little in
it as a new counselor I've spent quite a
lot of time baffled at what we're being
asked to vote for today I see that
indeed we need an appropriate corporate
plan I get the reason for their for the
for the resolution but the
recommendation from cabinet that we're
being asked to vote on still doesn't
make sense even after that very
informative PowerPoint and this useful
debate now what when trying to work out
what we're being asked to agree on I
looked around I found the previous
strategic plan that's being replaced I
found all those background documents but
I couldn't find anything else I couldn't
find corporate outcomes service plans
projects register people strategy and so
on and so forth so I came to the
conclusion that this isn't a corporate
plan it's a picture and it's an appendix
of 651 words what it is perhaps as a
plan for action to compile a corporate
plan or it's a framework for a corporate
plan and those are all good things and
no doubt if we'd been asked to to adopt
those frameworks plans for plans etc etc
we would have been a bit happier because
we'd have seen a way through to where we
were going but why wasn't it described
as as why is it referred to as a
corporate plan as as depicted in a
visual representation now I'm going to
agree with those who said how are we
going to explain this to our residents I
would love to know from somebody how how
people will how to answer people that
then say so what's in this corporate
plan
I'm counselor mantle he have already
spoken uh I understand that I have
already spoken but I think you've all
got a piece of paper in front of you
well I've certainly been given a piece
of paper and as I said I missed the
beginning of the session in that I
listened to councilor Higgs and and yet
I'd love to be able to work with you
honestly and truly and I and I don't
actually have a problem with the concept
of a visualization of a corporate plan I
may be the only one on this side of the
table who doesn't have a problem with it
but but as I said before we didn't have
any input and the thing that I believe
is missing from the plan if we're
talking about what's missing we have a
theme of environment but I don't believe
that that is the same as environmental
sustainability and since all of those
previous documents and the election we
as a council have declared a climate
emergency so I honestly believe that the
environmental sustainability should be
one of the all-encompassing things not
just 1/6 of a segment to whatever it is
so I would like to move the amendment
that I believe you've all got on piece
of paper in front of you that the
council adopts a draft corporate plan
based on a visual representation shown
in paragraph four point-five but with
inclusion of an environmental
sustainability theme which includes but
it's not limited to resource management
transport built environment biodiversity
etc and that in underpins all activity
within the council in line with the
climate emergency which was declared on
July the 27th 2019 the final design of
the corporate plan is to be agreed by
the three group leaders in advance of
any publication do you have a seconder I
would like to second the proposal
and thank you cancel it morally do you
accept this amendment I do not so will
route of their debate about the
amendment
the buttons as well and get it in this
size now III can't accept this I
understand that the the principle but
for me if you try and draw everything
down on a too narrow basis we've already
got loud and clear and they're the
environment we're all concerned about
these things I absolutely get your point
but I think as as things can change
having that block there to include all
sorts of parts of the environmental
impress for me that's enough and if you
tie yourselves down too tightly and
circumstances change it cause difficulty
and what happens if all three group
leaders do not actually agree then I
think you're going to be back and I'm
not what didn't really want to mention
the word BRICS it's also Berko instead
but you could have all sorts of
difficulties so we really got to be
careful for me having that building
block there of the environment is
exactly what we need absolutely agree
with that and that's why should we
supporting as it is but I'm afraid I
can't
Sarah support your proposal here that's
a stringer isn't that shame really
because this amendment actually complies
with what you were calling out for
earlier trying to work together
yes we're upset because I've been
excluded right up until this point we
make our point we stamp our fee and then
we try and be constructive and wouldn't
be horrible if we needed to change our
tack which means we're locking ourselves
down
so if suddenly we had we became truly
environmentally sustainable as a council
this would stop us changing our tactic
wouldn't it be a wonderful place to get
to so I think that's rather dancing on
the head of a pin
so I personally think I've I just see
the amendment is actually trying to do
what you've criticized us for not doing
today so happily support the amendment
um councillor Fleming yes good I feel I
need to to say something about the
proposed amendment more I has every have
every sympathy with the idea
incorporating environmental
considerations into everything the
council does we already have the
environment just one of our main
different missions here visions whatever
you want you'd like to call it and I
don't see why adding anything else to it
in terms of the plan can do anything but
muddy the waters it in you know we're
not suggesting that for any of the other
topics why are we doing it with
environment I'm not sure that actually
environment is in terms of what the
district's duties are it's different to
taking care of housing planning and the
other functions that we do because
environmental stewardship carries
through everything we do and I think
that will be made very clear when the
task force finishes its work and we have
no new environmental strategy that
brings that very point out so I will not
be supporting the amendment cancel it
Ben
thank you very much - I think this is a
vital component if you want to put it in
pick tall terms I would put a line
saying a sustainability above the local
plan and between your strategies if that
helps for you to visualize it this is a
vitally important amendment and this is
again as you say working with you here
it's unfortunate that we get to the
point of a full council meeting where we
can make these kind of points it would
have been great to workshop them with
with my colleagues but we're looking at
sustainable home so you're telling me
within our housing element we don't want
to stain war homes we don't want low
heating bills for our residents we don't
want affordable to make them more
affordable for them to live in by having
well insulated homes so that with their
low bills they can afford to take that
part-time job and also their their job
as a carer within their own family you
know we were by encouraging volunteers
to look after their parish greens and
make them Pleasant places - for wildlife
that that's a be a great thing to
encourage to ensure that within
transport we're having interconnected
footpaths
for people to be able to walk to work to
be able to integrate better with a bus
service this strand runs throughout
everything everything we do as a council
we've declared a climate emergency in
fact you are the ones that actually put
forward a client emergency and we
supported you in that so it actually
underpins everything that we do and it
hopefully will be throughout be running
through the local plan when that is
actually the final draft cut comes out
so I think there was no reason
whatsoever to vote this down is so clear
where it should be positioned and how it
should be as the actual heart of
everything do as a council thank you
very much chair councillor Hicks
councillor Richardson
Thank You chair I have Sam I'm slightly
skeptical about this motion for for two
reasons I think firstly which I'll touch
upon later that it's not really a single
amendment I think it's realistically to
firstly around the issue of
environmental sustainability I can I can
see I think where this principle is
coming from but I think first of it
because this environment strategy is
still emerging I think it would be wrong
to try and say that it isn't sustainable
that it's not unless we see the actual
finished product is not for us to try it
and and and and try and define it in
advance and I think generally speaking
with the six strategies we have as part
of this corporate plan if a strategy
isn't sustainable it's not a strategy it
has no value I think if we're going to
be scrutinizing this and saying it is or
isn't sustainable then that's something
which happens when we have concrete
ideas about what our outcomes are and
the second reason why I'm slightly
skeptical by this is because for all the
merits of that first part of the motion
it's the second part of the motions that
troubles me that the final design if it
has to be agreed by the three group
leaders and that to me seems like it's
trying to tie the hands of this council
if there are like there is today if
there are currently 17 councilors in
this on this side of the chamber and 15
on the other if we've been told that
unless we have the agreement of each of
the group leaders we can't pass it if
it's the will of the council but the
three group leaders haven't agreed it to
me that seems to be completely
undemocratic we are putting this out for
discussion in scrutiny if there's
improvements to be made around
sustainability let their discussion
happen there but I think we should
reject this motion and support the
substantive corporate plan can't
sleeking thank you worked out my Dawkins
by now I just wanted to make the point
perhaps to councillor Fleming and others
who feel that who want to ask why is the
environment in any way different to any
of the other priorities well I would
draw your attention to the the climate
emergency that was
that was announced by this council on
the 27th of July we haven't as far as I
know I've got communities emergency or a
well-being emergency or a customer's
emergency or a housing emergency or even
an economic emergency but we have got an
environment emergency which is as
counselor even says underpinning
everything we do even more than the
local plan which itself is is
underpinned by our need to continue to
have sustainable life on this planet and
in this country and indeed even in this
district so that is the difference that
is why this is such an important
amendment councillor Humphries
I'm sure thank you I'm actually going to
offer you a big hug actually councillor
man so it's really nice that you're
candid enough to agree that this is a
good plan and thank you for being honest
it's really appreciated thank you also
for the comments the comments about the
environment we share all of those
comments we live in the same planet
we're completely with you on that
absolutely but the reason I can't
support this really is just because I've
kept the contents within it I don't
actually get what you're trying to do
and I actually do support your view
ambition but it's just the way it's
written and it's where it says that it's
going to underpin all activity within
the council well to me that's a bit so
you can't really do that I don't think
and I also disagree with a three group
leader decision because you're
absolutely right Harry
this would be a breakdown of democracy
that's why we're all here that's where
all the debate and that's why we share a
vote and the outcome of that vote
decides the way we go and I think that's
the right proper way to do how much to
continue doing so but I do welcome your
thoughts as I said the same as ours
thank you for actually agreeing with us
on a few points maybe we should do more
of it and maybe we should discuss this
open the outside as well between
ourselves so we don't get to this
debacle thank you yeah could I just ask
on a point of order if you appreciate if
you like this amendment but you're just
a bit nervous about the wording can we
amend the wording of this amendment
sorry to be ignorant by I was only
elected in May
Thank You chair we have to deal with
each amendment as it comes so we might
be okay to tweak a word or two but
actually if it's changing the context we
can't we have to deal with that
amendment if that gets defeated you can
of course table another amendment thank
you thank you sure it's been mentioned
that the council that this council has
declared a climate emergency and that's
going to influence a lot of the
activities that this council undertakes
going forward and that's quite rightly
so and nobody on this side of the fence
would object to that in any shape or
form it also been mentioned that the
purpose of this motion is to bring up to
bring to the table the concept of
environmental sustainability now in my
book if this council does not have a
sustainable economic plan a sustainable
environment plan sustainable communities
indeed any type of sustainable planning
and action that we take we will not have
a viable community and so for me
sustainability is embedded in this
framework an architecture that been set
forth today and we should I think
embrace that and then as we move forward
in discussing the more detailed elements
of this and how we engage with our
residents and customers because we do
have customers despite councillor
Matheson's objection to the word then I
think we can begin to flesh out some of
the elements that under came what we're
trying to do so from that point of view
and given what a councillor Richardson
and others have said I cannot possibly
survive and I support this amendment I'm
against the war boys
it's be very interesting I invite my
original concerns were in paragraph 10
environmental implications
we now have an amendment and it it sort
of get things are getting very muddled
up it's a real good case I think if not
we all see the wood for the trees the
environment is not a building block it's
a foundation everything depends upon the
environment we can't have a housing
strategy without an environment the
environment should be really sort of
shown by a continuous ring that
underpins all the council's activities
all its plans everything the council
does has a carbon entrance it has
consequences for emissions there is
nothing within this corporate plan which
is gonna last for the next eight years
about auditing the council's carbon
emissions if we don't start counting the
council's carbon emissions we're never
going to know whether what they were
what they will be or what they're going
to be it's vital I think now that we set
a sort of clear strategy for how we are
going to look at the environmental
consequences we need to start now
auditing it needs to be the framework
within which our environmental task
force works there needs to be a clear
frame of reference that is why we need
to put within this visualization that
the environment underpin Z talk it's not
a case of the trees it's not a case of
biodiversity it's about the carbon
emissions of the council and its
activities it is wrong when it says here
there are no immediate environmental
implications arising from the adoption
of a revised corporate plan of course
there are everything we decide will have
consequences if we order meeting it has
consequences for the environment if we
stop using paper it has consequences we
use more electricity to look at the
documents on our laptops so I'm
supporting this amendment because it
places the environment right at the
heart of what we do as Emerson Thank You
Jay
so I'm sensing a slight contradiction in
some of the messaging point from the
administration tonight on this issue so
cancer Richardson and counselor at Kane
Young said absolutely yeah the the
environmental issue does indeed envelope
all of the issues and from councilor
Humphreys objected to the point in the
motion that says it underpins all
activity within the counter so I'm
interested in generally interested in
and you might be right
what are those things that aren't don't
come within that and below and if and
yeah if there aren't things then why
does that lead you to reject reject the
motion thank you we're not I'm debating
the amendment so I'm I'm sorry we're not
we're not can't cancel that Humphries
cannot answer your questions at this
point Network
motivating amendment and not it's not a
question and answer right so counselor
Pratt yeah Thank You counselor war boys
for putting that really succinctly I
don't think I can put it better myself
and counselor opinion you have said that
sustainability is in everything that we
do as a council so why not just agree
with the amendment and stick it on the
plan another thing I would just like to
mention is that you you have said to us
as the administration that this is just
a framework things that we can kind of
ad hoc kind of stick things on to it and
you know in that capacity
putting sustainability at the heart of
it should not and would not affect the
outcomes of the environment task force
group so I think that you know there's
no there's no kind of underhand sort of
thing going on here and I think that
yeah if everything that you've said
there about sustainability being at the
heart of everything the council does is
true then vote the amendment
um cast a field
thank you I think our to welcome counts
the war boys input but I really feel
that we've been listening to deeper
meaningful intellectual debates for a
substantial time and I come to the
delusion that in 18 years as a counselor
I have never ever known one of your
councilors vote against the group
decision and I recognize that there are
17 of you on that side of the chamber
and 15 of us on this side of the chamber
so why don't we just put this to the
vote and stop wasting our time
is that proposal I'm John this and a
proposal have we got a seconder Thank
You councillor Phillips I'm gonna sure
we put this to the vote then whether we
vote on it or not all those in favor of
going to okay so we're showing hands on
the amendment here all those in favor
and all this against right so that's
lost so now I'm I think it's done a lot
of talking we're gonna go straight to
the vote at the substantive motion so
all those in favor of that all those
against right that's um carried right so
we're moving on to amend item agenda
item 11
the Hawley neighborhood development plan
I'd like to invite councilor burn to
introduce his paper and move the
recommendation in the report thank you
Jim chair councilors the report before
you updates Council on the holy
neighbourhood plan and recommends that
in light of the recent local referendum
result that one it be formally made that
is adopted as part of this councils
development plan and two that a decision
statement to this effect be published
with immediate effect work on this plan
commenced in late 2015 and it has been
through an extensive period of
preparation public consultation and has
been independently examined
paragraph 2.1 reminds us that if the
majority of those who votes are in favor
of the draft plan then it must be made
by the local planning authority within
eight weeks of the referendum the
referendum took place on the 29th of
August and as set out in Section four
the declared result was as follows the
total number of votes cast was 345 which
was a 25.8%
turnout the number of yes votes cast
were 304 and that was 88% of all the
votes cast a number of no votes cast was
forty twelve percent a number of void
ballot papers one paragraph four point
six refers to the draft final section
statement appended to the report a copy
of this will be sent to the Parish
Council and be published on the
appropriate page on the council website
the remaining sections of the report
provide details on the financial and
legal implications of the decision to
adopt this plan this decision today
means that the holy neighbourhood plan
becomes the fifth such plan to be
formally adopted in itself now finally I
would like to take this opportunity to
offer my congratulations to all those
who've been involved in getting this
plan this stage allows the council
endorsed the recommendations as I set
out in the report thank you and at this
point I would need a second of these
Thank You chair I'd be delighted a
second tip thank you to councillor Byrne
for proposing this this referendum took
place at the end of August we'd have
liked to have seen at last month's
meeting and it's a shame that many of
the people involved aren't able to be
here but the traveling time
and such precludes reclusive that this
evening however it's really great to see
this coming forward and I congratulate
all those involved from my first mention
of it to a parish council meeting to
various parish council chairs taking it
on and then consequently encouraging a
very committed group into taking it to
conclusion and hopefully this is some of
the community leadership mentioned
earlier in our in our meeting this has
involved thousands and thousands of
hours of volunteer time and those of you
who haven't been involved in they who
have been involved in neighborhood town
will know what I mean and yes some
professionals involved it needs to be
and paid for but the majority of work is
my calling on those in the parish to
work together whether it's holding an
exhibition whether it's delivering
leaflets taking photos of key views
briefing professional bodies drafting
checking checking again and writing the
plan it is a huge effort and has finally
paid off for the adoption of this plan
today it's also a great comfort to
groups such as this to see neighborhood
planning policy being taken into account
planning committees such as at the
meeting on 16th of October where an
application was refused due to
non-compliance with that particular
neighborhood loan and and finally
reference my first point I'd really like
to thank all the offices concerned those
sitting here tonight and I reiterate
reiterate the point I've made it at
least three of these meetings that we do
need to have more resource here at with
Suffolk to support communities to bring
their plans forwards but I congratulate
the community of Hawley in bringing this
forward this plan today and I urge
everyone here to support it thank you
very much to you does anyone have any
questions okay we'll move straight to
the vote
all those in favor all those against
but that's Carrie so moving on to know
what would you like to say we like to
have taken the opportunity a very rare
opportunity for a county counselor to
speak about planning issue and mid
Suffolk meeting to be able to bring some
of that view into the chamber is
actually quite helpful I'd like to
personally thank all the volunteer
effort because I've helped some of the
groups and and the individuals have been
involved in this what's really an animal
so to reiterate last week we had a
committee here unanimously back and made
a neighborhood plan against a
recommendation of an officer
non-balanced recommendation and that was
very powerful and I think very pivotal
so I just like to reiterate all those
that will be I hope using this plan and
future plans we've got on the agenda
tonight in the future because I think
they can become a valuable tool in
actually empowering communities to
decide where the housing goes to make
their communities truly sustainable
thank you thank you so we'll go back to
the vote
so all those in favor that's carried I'm
unanimously so on
agenda item 12 the Thurston Neighborhood
Development Plan I'd like to invite
councillor Byrne to introduce this paper
and move the recommendation in the
report thank you very much oh yes this
second report which follows the same
format as the item just discussed
updates the council on the progress of
the Thurston neighborhood plan and in
light of the recent local referendum
result it too recommends that the
neighbourhood plan be formally made and
that a decision statement to this effect
be published with immediate effect and
that referendum took place on the 12th
of September and the declared result was
as follows the total number of votes
cast was 860 which was a
2.8 7% turnout the number of yes votes
cast was 824 approximately 96% and the
number of no votes cast was 35
approximately 4% the number of void
ballot papers again was 1 now that
decision today means that the first
neighborhood plan becomes the sixth such
plan to be formally adopted in midst of
it and as with all ii my congratulations
to all those who worked on the
neighborhood plan and I ask again that
the council endorsed the recommendation
as set out in the report councillor
Richard thank you chair and thank you to
councilor burned for introducing this
report I'm delighted to - second
recommendation before you like many
counselors have said already I just want
to say thank you to all of the hard work
that has gone into the to the production
of this plan by individuals and of
course by Thurston Parish Council in
particular this is a very thorough and
detailed plan and I think it offers real
benefits to the local community and will
have a tangible impact on local planning
policy I too like how Steven and
councillor stringer was there at the
meeting in the 16th of October and saw
the real impact that neighborhood plans
can have and I hope that this will offer
residents in Thurston a chance to have a
voice in local planning that will be
heard and will be considered and viewed
sympathetically by the council I think
this is a real achievement for Thurston
I think it was significantly benefit the
overwhelming majority of people who
voted in favor of it in the referendum
and I hope the council offer it its
unreserved in the vote thank you I'm
moving to questions and anyone who wants
to speak to the motion councillor
mansome thank you in that in Council
turnest
absence I would like to echo a lot of
councillor Richardson's thoughts about
person and its neighborhood plan an
awful lot of hard work has gone into it
and I too hope that council is able to
support thirst as they
anyone else like to speak so it moves
straight to the boat all those in favor
that's unanimous and therefore carry
agenda item 13 at cancel appointments I
would like to invite councillor Morley
to introduce this item
[Applause]
[Music]
this is to agree the following
appointments on the community governance
review working group bit of a mouthful
I'm replacing councilor Julie Flatman
and counselor John Whitehead
will be replacing councilor James Caston
on this working group can I have a
seconder please are there any further
changes than addition to those already
tabled all those in favor
perhaps unanimous that's been carried to
so that's the end the date of the next
meeting is Thursday the 12th of December
5:30